[Musique]
je vais demander à jessica de mettre son
oreiller 1 puisque maintenant on va
parler plein de choses en télé je vous
dis on va parler de the voice on va
parler de la parodie du jour on va
parler de plein de choses et vous aurez
géraldine maillet votre oreille vous
devrez dire tout ce que vous dit
géraldine maillet regardais les dans
l'oreille elle voilà est ce que vous
voulez qu'on fasse un test tout de suite
du radis na li zhi titre eu quelque
chose à jessica très bien aller très
bien
non parce qu'elle a répondu ouvrait
alors qu bien d'accord ok j'ai pas
compris moi je suis très content d'être
là ce soir c'est tout oui vous est pour
moi la meilleure émission d'access prime
time
merci ses sets compliqués longue au post
un spectacle à la fois fédérateur
oui et réconfortant d'accord ok j'aurais
compris à ce que j'ai dit
[Applaudissements]